Sometimes, changes like a new school year can mean new feelings...
...for an old person in your life.
But what if you don't know how someone feels about you?
It may take a little detective work.
Take note of when this potential crush talks to you at school.
If it's just in front of friends then it may be flirting for attention.
But if no one else is around then it may be an effort on his part...
...to get to know you more.
Sometimes, the clues are online.
Does he constantly like your selfies or comment on your post?
That could mean he wants to know more.
Create alone time that doesn't feel like a date.
Plan a study session together.
This way, if there isn't actual chemistry between you two,...
...at least there will be progress on that chemistry homework.